tell this story because to me
it just scared the out of me that
really that they could say can you how
fast can you learn a monologue
um
well really that story is i tell this
this story all the time because it's to
me it's a testament to
to jerry and larry david about not
giving up on something until it's right
so we the ending of that episode
um for those people who may not remember
it my storyline was
jerry had met an old a girl that i had
always wanted to date high school and in
order to impress her on my behalf
told her that i was a marine biologist
and then when he tells me that i go i ca
that's not one of the things i can fake
i don't know how to fake that so i was
trying to pawn myself off as a marine
biologist
and my storyline in that episode ended
when i was walking with her on the beach
and there's suddenly a beached whale and
somebody else out is there a marine
biologist and you see me
you know like i'm a dead man walking off
into the ocean to see if i can do
anything that's well that was the end of
my story
and then the taping in front of the live
audience there was a scene that i wasn't
in with jerry and cramer and maybe lamb
but i think it was just jerry and kramer
which was supposed to be the end of
kramer's storyline and it was fine it
was funny but
it it i guess the guys just weren't
satisfied with the live audience
response they just thought it wasn't
good enough to be the out for the show
so as they always did the writers
circled the wagons and the bands started
to play and these and then larry came
over and he went
clearly they had gotten an inspiration
in the circle
larry said how long would it take you to
learn a monologue and i said how long
how long a monologue you said a page and
a half a couple minutes you know what
and he had written this monologue you
know the sea was angry that day my
friends and
kramer had a storyline where he had been
hitting golf balls into the ocean to
practice his drive
but they had never thought of why would
there be a beached whale oh there's a
golf ball in the blowhole so when they
had that inspiration
they wrote this monologue for george to
reveal that he went out and pulled the
golf ball out of the blue hole
there's no time or place to rehearse it
so they put some screens up between us
and the audience we got on into the set
and the camera guys were given their
shots
we did one run-through of it just for
ourselves just to make sure we had the
lines and they pulled the screens away
and said to the audience they're going
to try something we'll see if it works
and
what you see when you watch that episode
is the first and only time
we shot that new rewrite and that became
one of the most
it's one of the big highlight laughs of
the entire series that was a laugh when
i eventually pulled the golf ball out of
my pocket to show it to kramer is that a
titleist
is that a titleist
there was a solid minute or more of
laughter which that's a lot of laughing
where you can't go on you can't do the
next line because the audience is
laughing that hard that was huge i mean
but to me
if a director came up and said how fast
can you learn a monologue i'd probably
say a week
maybe a week really
very very
a monologue i mean what if you said you
couldn't like your mind doesn't work
like that do you think any cast member
could have done that
uh
i know julia could have done it um
i don't know
probably jerry could have done i don't
know about mike but uh because mike's
mike was always more of a physical guy
than the words um
yeah it's just one of those things i
never struggled with i i learned i did a
one-man play
in los angeles years ago where i played
harry truman i mean it's a play it's a
two-act play
you know i learned it in two weeks two
weeks you probably learned
50 monologues
it was it was 80 pages of a monologue
yeah